ambassador
sir you'll hear everything in the poll
sorry russia's u.n delegation under
scrutiny as it arrived at a security
council meeting hastily convened at the
united kingdom's request
this is the first time a state
has attacked a fueled and functioning uh
nuclear power plant
and it is clearly outlawed by
international law uh and the geneva
conventions
nuclear please in ukraine the director
general of the international atomic
energy agency briefing via video link
from onboard a plane confirmed a
building adjacent to the zaparisia
nuclear plant was hit but said its six
nuclear reactors remain intact
russia blamed ukrainian saboteurs for
provoking its forces in the area
today's meeting is another attempt by
kiev authorities to kindle artificial
hysteria around what is happening in
ukraine and they're being assisted in
this by their western backers
ukraine accused russia of nuclear
terrorism and warned that no one is safe
we have survived the night that could
have stopped the history of ukraine and
europe indeed every day provides us with
newer and newer evidence that
it is not only ukraine honda russian
attack
it is europe
it is the entire world
it is humanity
many countries demanded russia's
withdrawal and expressed concern for the
ukrainian crews left manning not only
the zaparisia facility but also the
chernobyl site also under russian
control so this imminent danger
continues
we narrowly avoided a disaster last
night
the international community must be
unanimous
in demanding russia's forces
stop their dangerous assault
the director general of the iaea is
offering to meet with russian and
ukrainian officials at the chernobyl
nuclear site in the hopes of reaching an
agreement to secure all of the country's
nuclear facilities amid dire warnings
that the worst of this conflict is yet
to come
kristin salumi al-jazeera the united
nations